[Musik]
hell auf alle miteinander und herzlich
willkommen zur sail israels heute gibt's
ein oder beziehungsweise 12 34 faschings
rezepte und zwar wenn das herzhafte
gerichte die man wirklich toll auf einem
buffet anrichten kann nicht nur zur
faschingszeit ihr können das auch zu
silvester aber bis dahin ist noch ein
bisschen oder auch zu jeder anderer
feier im prinzip ja sowieso richtig paar
stücken obwohl mit dem umzug des
erfinders und ich find's schön immer die
kinder schön zu schminken oder schminke
faschingskostüme bastl das macht mir
schon viel spaß aber man muss dazu sagen
bei uns hier ist faschingshochburg und
hier ist schon ziemlich schmutzig ja
aber man muss auch ehrlich sagen waschen
bei euch im anschluss anderes als heute
schwaben es sich aus einem kleinen dorf
kommt da war fast das einzige highlight
im ganzen jahr
ja und ich will nicht sagen was ich sage
es mal nicht was alles passiert ist nach
hause kommt die wissen was ich meine
okay es war immer der wahnsinn ja aber
fasching da keiner nicht dann muss ich
sagen er war schüchtern in waghäusel
muss man auch mal erlebt haben da ist
alles schwarz usw
ihr könnt aber schreiben wie bei euch
fasching oder karneval gefeiert wird
also bald gelegt und jetzt geht es um
die rezepte ich habe hier einmal mini
hot dogs die sind wirklich cool und vor
allem sehr praktisch kamera ein bisschen
ketchup und so umgucken anrichten
hier haben wir so einen strudel aus yoga
teig der ist gefüllt mit pasta also mit
dieser knoblauch mit dem knoblauch
schinken und cheddar käse
hier haben wir kalte füße also stinkt
füße und case für mich etwas
stinkefinger machen müssen aber es
stinkt enden käsehändler ist sieht aus
wie eine hülle wollen
und hier haben wir noch schlagen konfekt
das ist halt auch perfekt da kann man
verschiedene tipps und aufstrichen damit
dazu anbieten und ich zeige euch das
ganze jetzt hier in diesem video oder
jetzt starten wir auch direkt
jetzt starte ich mit den laugen konfekt
und den mini hotdogs
aus 150 milliliter warmem wasser 21
gramm hefe einem teelöffel zucker 150 g
naturjoghurt 50 milliliter milch 600
gramm mehl eineinhalb teelöffel salz und
40 gramm weiter butter stelle ich jetzt
den hefeteig her da für verhöre ich das
wasser mit der hefe und dem zucker
und jetzt fühle ich alle zutaten hinzu
und lasse den teig etwa fünf minuten
kneten
[Musik]
wenn der teig schön geschmeidig ist wird
er jetzt zu einer kugel geformt und dann
lasse ich ihn abgedeckt für eine stunde
ruhen
[Musik]
aus der hälfte des tages vor mich jetzt
einen langen strang mit etwa 3 cm
durchmesser
in der zwischenzeit lasse ich jetzt auch
einen liter wasser mit 50 gramm natron
aufkochen
das ist dann nämlich unsere lauge jetzt
stellt sich mit einer tankkarte oder ihr
könnt auch ein messer verwenden kleine
stücke ab so dass wir eben das leben von
fact formen können
[Musik]
und sobald das wasser kocht gebe ich
jetzt das laufen konflikt hinein
dann gab es ein paar sekunden drin
schwimmen und dann kommt direkt aufs
backblech und wer möchte kann das augen
konfekt jetzt noch mit mohn sesam mit
chili sauce oder mit kürbiskernen oder
auch sonnenblumenkernen bestreuen
[Musik]
und dann kann das laufen konfekt
gebacken werden
[Musik]
den restlichen teig drollig jetzt zu
einem langen strang aus und dann
halbiert ihn und jetzt habe ich hier so
kleine mini würstchen und die lege ich
jetzt hier rein
entwickeln sie dann mit dem teig 1
[Musik]
jetzt ist eine hände zu drücken und dann
immer abknipsen
[Musik]
jetzt werden die mini hot dogs noch mit
etwas eiweiß bestreichen und mit sesam
bestreut und dann können sie auch schon
gebacken werden
[Musik]
jetzt sind die käse füße an der reihe
diese werden aus einem teig zubereitet
und den mürbeteig bereit ich jetzt so
aus 150 gramm butter 150 gramm
geriebener käse 250 gramm mehl jeweils
einem halben teelöffel salz und
backpulver einem viertel teelöffel
pfeffer und paprikapulver und 100 gramm
sahne den teig bereitet jetzt am besten
in einem mixer zu der soll nämlich gar
nicht lange geknetet werden
dafür gebe ich jetzt einfach die butter
den geriebenen käse das meersalz
backpulver den pfeffer paprikapulver und
die sahne in einen mixer und phenix
alles so lange bis der teig homogen ist
alternativ könnt ihr natürlich auch die
knethaken verwenden
[Musik]
der teig riecht wie käse post für dich
als käse nicht liebhaber nicht zur
ganzes lieblingsrezept aber es passt zum
titel
am besten nimmt anstinken käse
[Musik]
jetzt ist der teig gut verknetet ist
aber ein bisschen klebrig daher kommt
der jetzt abgedeckt in den kühlschrank
und auf zwei stunden ruhen
jetzt ist der käse fuß teig schön kalt
und ich kann ihnen aus rollen auf 5
millimetern und dann mit hilfe von zwei
ausstechen einfach aufstecken
[Musik]
jetzt können die käse füße und
käsehändler mit eiweiß bestrichen werden
und wer möchte kann sie noch mit
kräutern bestreuen und so werden sie
dann im vorgeheizten backofen gebacken
bis sie schön goldbraun sind jetzt geht
es weiter mit dem strudel dafür brauche
ich zwei youth kompletter geht schon
fertig im tiefkühl oder im kühlregal 200
gramm schmandt 100 gramm passt immer das
ist ein türkischer schinken und
hunderter käse für den strudel frühere
ich jetzt zuerst den schmand mit dem ei
und breite dann die ewv kompletter vor
mir aus jetzt bestreite ich das juca
blatt mit der einmischung und belege ist
dann mit dem basteln und dem käse
[Musik]
jetzt werden die zwei seiten
eingeschlagen und der rest war zu einer
langen rolle geformt die rolle setze ich
jetzt auf mein parkett backblech das
habe ich vorher mit back prinz will
eingefettet die zwei strudel werden
jetzt noch mit der restlichen
einmischung gestrichen und wenn ihr
möchtet könnt ihr jetzt auch sesam
darüberstreuen
und so werden sie dann im vorgeheizten
backofen gebacken bis sie goldbraun sind
jetzt sind alle fertig und murat darf
sich jetzt mal habt durchprobieren
eigentlich kaum einmal hier strudel und
man kann darauf alles warm oder auch
kalt essen und sehr gut vorbereitet dass
rappaz deswegen so genial ist vielleicht
ein eigenes video gebraucht ja ich weiß
was doch nicht soll ich hab alles in ein
packungen oder alles getrennt meinung
kommen du musst dich durch probieren
sagt mit ketchup wagen laufen erstmals
an balsam dieses waren die kids wie ist
ein richtig gut ich hab sehr mit
bisschen von diesem frühjahr zubereitet
die brühe
ja die sind echt gut ihre mitstreiter
nicht vielleicht ein anderer
die sind echt ein wirbel richtig lecker
aber ohne catcher super oder
aber schmeckt alles tun als würde ich
das mit der mannschaft macht es nicht
braucht ist nach und spd kennt deren
gerne noch ergänzen mit zb gemüsesticks
einem joghurt dip dass man eben auch mal
was gesundes dabei hat was frisches und
natürlich auch ein süßes dessert und
dann könnt ihr euch auch prüfen genau da
könnt euch ideen aus meinen videos vom
letzten und vorletzten jahr einfach
anschauen
ich wünsche euch viel spaß beim
nachbacken viel spaß beim karneval ist
oder faschingsumzug ja übertreibst eine
farbliche trinkt wasser trieb nicht mehr
fragt ja genau wollte er sagen also bis
zum nächsten mal tschüss viel spaß und
ich nehme jetzt ein
laura perfekt genial
[Musik]
ich glaube ich diana und dodi
gray mäßig oder lieber aus comedy und
den hut unternimmt die die zipfelmütze
da ich kann es stets fragt sie ob sie
wird es an heißt der typ noch christin
tochter eröffnet es nicht
ich sehe gerade jetzt komm wir machen so
soll nach somalia wie gesagt bei uns
heller mond stubb